hmm hello and welcome to this video ya
got a new blitz game going with a little
bit irritated first game in a session
some our software they're active it's
weird so I've got whitey against max
power from Denmark and we got a free
door yeah when he takes the form i think
this is a very playable opening for
black actually it is a bit
underestimated I believe d5 now is the
critical move and after admit that I
don't really know how this works I think
white goes 'if I've but don't ask me
about details okay it doesn't do it so
at least a quick d 5 is not hitting me
and I don't want to play a 3 here I also
don't want to lose the Queen maybe if I
go back here I can go back and it's a
bad okay and then I can't cancel yeah I
have good control over d5 I always like
this kind of structure like a pawn on e4
against a pawn on d6 or c4 I against the
six like at the Budapest for example why
is always going to be a little bit
better unless he does something
extremely stupid so okay f4 let's grab
space it's more of an aggressive way to
play this okay i wonder i can go here or
to b2 b3 Bishop b2 also makes some sense
okay he wants to play Bishop c6 and put
pressure on this pawn hmm
okay lend some extra attention to it and
yeah but the ship c 6-r actually can do
94 again yeah it's not a big deal if I
go G for which I would like to do
actually yes got 9h form this is
something to watch out for I don't quite
get this now is now he has to go back it
didn't do all that much so this is all
nice and good but how do I actually get
somewhere I think I'll go here to
prepare you for which he prevents okay
that's probably a good move still h5
could be weakening it's not all all
great about this move how am I making
progress does he want to play b5 that's
possible I'm not quite sure here move
like f5 you will get the e5 square I
could put this night on g5 this is
actually interesting it is somewhat
annoying on that square
okay it doesn't threaten something
directly but it feels I like it put some
pressure on him isn't clean you one
basically forcing this piece back now I
mean okay that it doesn't really bother
him all that much I guess he can go back
to have six yeah maybe still
yeah yeah he can do that let that blonde
us the night queen age five days 90 f 6m
so that is a that is something that he
can do and I cannot go g5 because my
night Hanks interesting so how to how to
do this really put the CM now Channing
no I'm threatening queen age five it
probably has to take no it did not take
so what does that all mean so if i take
here is going to take with the pawn
check it's hard to believe I always find
it amazing how people decide on things
like that in a split second it just
barely holds a very very badly if it
does hold a man i'm not sure about it um
so I can check check and now I give you
five it's at least very dangerous
I take if he takes here he doesn't okay
so he doesn't he six doesn't win here
that's amazing okay let's take it maybe
takes 25 now I am Kevin it's probably
not not threatening all that much this
is hang with a check time morning it's
amazing that this is weird position it's
not falling apart maybe I'm just not
understanding just correctly which I
find it weird that this shouldn't be
winning for white somehow maybe maybe it
is but ok if you takes politics should
win actually on f7 if it takes e 696
Queen takes f5 and sorry I just a 26
sorry F takes Knight takes just wins
flat flat flat f6 though looks like crap
but might not win might not win for me
Knight f3 is a big threat though
threatening 94 and I'd age for things f
60 mi do i actually have even something
better like night f7 threatening night
h6 this is actually interesting
and maybe night f 749 h6 it could work
and now you're thinking for a long time
you can definitely not check who gave
two should be good and I'm threatening
to tea with the porn like EF seven for
Queen g8 made this is a very substantial
threat so so let's check again f6 maybe
I have something even more convincing
that I don't see okay so check graph to
why is that not winning look f7 mate is
the threat check so it is winning how do
I actually win here maybe just go back
he cannot take e six
am i threatening no I thought it'd be
seven maybe it's a black resin yeah I'm
also having Bishop before so guy he was
deciding on all this year very quickly
and it felt extremely dangerous to me so
let's let's get going maybe from this
position so here the engine gives me a
slight edge not more yeah maybe I mean I
definitely prefer white if you give me
the choice but it might not be all that
all that decisive would be eight yeah I
know I decided to put the night on to g5
that cannot be a bad bad square the
seven knobs should have three given by
the engine okay I affair this was
interesting and this fields extremely
dangerous okay if the engine wants to
take it hmm I didn't think of this movie
no I just saw like this and and stopped
a bit okay and this is a move that you
can easily overlook that's nice you have
to see I think after 92 web not sure but
I think Queen h5 should win them now I'm
actually meeting oh yes should I give
the Queen em so yeah so i can take this
actually check this all this was played
like instantly and it should win now he
five is even clearer probably a lot of
you can't cross here gtx wasn't wasn't a
clear-cut to me at all I was thinking
that I could try various things even
going back didn't seem completely
outlandish to me even it gives me a four
but his King position is weakened the
engine actually wants to instill play
this my head looks very strong King g7
when Drew g1 he gets killed on the GFR I
wouldn't have found that probably never
hear i'm winning a queen check
and f5 is actually clearer yeah that is
actually clearer but I don't think that
this could be bad yeah okay that wins
wins as well takes TX 6 and curtains so
I I played it quite quite quite ok and
here here there is really not much that
you can do this is chest losing out
right and here I think I wanted to go
night f7 idea would be night age six but
the engine feels feels is wrong of
course but it gives this one hi isn't
that winning no because luke t exactly
ah ok hiya ok ok he has checks he and
him so something like this is actually
losing check this this is winning for a
while after boo sugar too but he's got
this move can't my god that sets that
sets really if you lose to this here you
you can't biting biting into your desk
amazing that could have easily happened
I mean I would have thought for a moment
but still ok this is also seems to win
the idea is just to dislodge this night
somehow so that tweenage it made will
happen and he also does 94 an f5 so ok
it would have won but here enchanted was
actually Chinese here for me to find the
moves guarantee resign ok interesting I
think you've played it a bit too risky
with his age 58 sure thing ok thanks for
watching